previously on grave hoppers point of
today is for Rob to get to exactly 3:07
p.m. Pacific so he has survived an hour
and hallo the grunt rebellion all that
stuff how they like recruited
backstroking through the air Oh God see
that was a gun no shields oh I think
it's time for Dark Souls god damn it I'm
so slow come on oh come on
[Music]
yes oh that was a little tense oh my god
dude no this is it so close there's a
Ledge under this I don't care go up
sorry I knew that was there I'm sorry a
lot of this is Muslim oh jesus thank God
for that wooden Oh No what was that
no no I got invaded No
Oh No that's such bull get out of here
that's such bull I don't know why that's
I'm excited for this though oh oh you
choose to kill him right
you really didn't hesitate I think
they're square it wasn't I was waiting
for a prompt that was painful to watch
again yep that was pretty painful
welcome back to grave hoppers the show
where we put permadeath in every single
game if you die in a game you move on to
the next so one life per game last week
sucked you did yeah you know what yeah
you died but like that was a little bit
out of your reach deep I mean it was a
poor judgement call on a playing the
game online but also be I wanted to
Kindle that bonfire so I have ten Estus
flasks for the Taurus demon but I forgot
that I could be invaded and I forgot
that it was a new game technically it's
Dark Souls remastered so people are
actually playing at multiplayer and it
was one of you it was probably someone
watching because he it was insanely
great timing for him to be standing
there in the bridge in Kenya on the
other hand there's me where the fall
damage that was I think just a casual
slip forgot about you know when your
shields are off you were very vulnerable
to fall damage but that being said I
like to address something and this will
also relate to the list we've kind of
altered for the first time I should have
played I played lots of us but I should
have played on grouted mode because
clearly I was not familiar with the game
now that was embarrassing and I promise
you won't happen again
so last night I even played a bunch of
alien isolation I still don't feel that
comfortable so I'm gonna I thought we'd
we'd switched some things around so
we're will eventually get to alien
isolation but here's an updated list
here of our rip times last of us mm-hmm
a minute and 25 seconds
however I still I've clocked the best
time at fifty almost time yeah I am
sucking no but I'm sucking for pretty
bad with that a minute and twenty five
so we're onto Resident Evil 4 and what I
did is I swapped alien isolation with
Zelda breath awhile so if you die in
residue before we're gonna go to breath
of the wild a game that I'm very
familiar with compared to alien
isolation I played about an hour and a
half of alien isolation still don't feel
that comfortable with how you avoid the
alien so I want to give myself another
quad hunting twitch thing Mike is
assured us resi before we'll be fine
that's what I do with doom yeah but I
played this game far more I'm rolling
the entire now just if you're new the
show we don't really do well on
cutscenes just so we can get right to
the the nice gory action especially
glory in this game can I skip this yes
okay we're right into it yeah let me
just make sure I'm acclimated so this is
the ps4 remastered version see I wasted
a bullet and you were playing on a
difficult it's the it's a so this game
is was one of the first ones we wanted
to do because it has the dynamic
difficulty that they hide the longer you
survive in resin before and the harder
it gets it like reacts so that could
make this season so to speak really
interesting or this episode possibly
more than one episode what time where we
go until today I got to survive until
307 307 because there's a dude right
here that I'm about to so I'm gonna skip
this as well so I am of the father
whoops
I am uh of the school where I try to
knock him down the knife um he's Spanish
I'm in Spain this remote village this is
a lianas Kennedy s doesn't stand for
anything there's like Ulysses s cramp
but he's uh he's on a mission to save
the president's daughter for those who
have not played this one of the all-time
greats this game yeah you know skip over
he's calling his handler huh negan so
now there's some stuff going down in
here I can't look at this for a lot wow
it looks it seems pretty tough to peek
around oh yeah this is this is the old
school they haven't addressed people's
sick for the first resonable to allow
you know that's not resi will six yeah
and then revelation for the first to
allow you to move while aiming rest
equal to is also going to and that's
what we played a little bit yeah
oh yeah this games like a cheesy soap
opera so you get you see my health down
the bottom right you've got it there i'm
guys haha yeah so you get so you stun
them and then you do this stuff or to
save ammo you can I'll pull out my knife
there's a guy up right behind me
so I'm doing this just to conserve ammo
because then yeah I can take out my
knife and hit him on the ground
some people are of the thought that the
headshots just the traditional headshots
just are the best way to go and I might
switch it up depending on how
comfortable I am with each approach you
can hear that wolf so there's no point
saving but normally obviously you save
it typewriters here we go
I don't think snakes in there okay um
you can hear this wolf is stuck in a
bear trap and I got a friendly wolf
so yeah it's actually kind of cool if
you save him later on he will save you
and by later on I mean a few minutes
from here it's also a good way for the
game without being overt it tells you
there's bear traps to watch out for and
whatnot so those could mess me up if I'm
not careful I came over there's a jewel
here yet I don't think so
so in the long run this game will be I
don't actually I don't know one I don't
talk about yet you got explosives there
I'm going to avoid those bear traps
all right so this is fun I can just lure
this dude into the bombs if I do it
correctly I'll lure him to the other
direction
oh you got it Wow shoot out his feet
yeah might as well just not let me
replay the game you get Leon's Raccoon
City Police Department SWAT uniform
choose one with someone in it
nope oh that woman was not looking too
good
oh the in the pitchfork yeah where are
these guys down the hill whoo
they're very creepy yep oh they're so
they're not technically uh zombies yeah
they are it is called the so the ganado
z' they're granado's but they're
infected by los lagos I might have gone
that wrong people
concurrent now I think I saw someone
mention that in the chat and now it
makes more sense but yeah I'm in Spain
if that cases people are wondering why
uh regimes in Spanish I never played
this game a bear trap no I think I'm
good but this looks much much much
better than the game does on this game
has been on so many platforms it's
actually really good on the weak I don't
know if you got the chance to play that
version the aiming was awesome come on
yeah get out of here so yeah like every
once in a while the game will get more
difficult if I don't die so that's what
scares me about this game let's blog
asset controls again autos thank you all
right
famous fitly a village scene got a
little Metal Gear Solid kind of yeah
cutscenes here it's so it's weird here
they're not that far away
no also it kind of reminds me of Empire
Strikes Back yeah
the walkers whoa no zoom yeah yeah yeah
yeah those quick soon okay cool so the
shotguns up here I'm gonna try not to
bother them until I have to there's
someone over here I think
Chuck Eric Green says just a daily
corpse fire morning good morning what
yellow yeah it's pretty bad huh so give
that so this part I'm just kind of
surviving oh whoa before I forget do you
have health yep combine it with that
combining green and red pretty much
refills your entire health when you make
them but there's an inventory management
this game that uh oh god there's a
chainsaw dude I hear where's the shotgun
yeah I heard it too
chill Dan over something next that
chicken yeah what's up vault TV I don't
know where the chain side is the
shotguns up here in the building I'm
just gonna avoid the chainsaw dudes like
I said so now I'm boxed in here just
will slow him down a little bit
whoa sorry I was tapping that instead of
holding it get all this [ __ ] grenades up
here too
if I remember correctly
normally I would even just keep running
around at this part as you you'll see
you just wait for the church bells to
ring but I might resort to the shotgun
if the chainsaw dude threatens to end
this episode early wait until the damn
did shoot those out of the air - we're
coming fairly slow
when you do you sorry I'll have four
states / - I remember putting that up Oh
where's the chainsaw dude no come in
here oh yeah oh dude you
yeah Dame says don't get cornered get
pretty good advice
yeah the last time I saw this was I was
we were doing Evel Knievel yeah
this was the second-longest season
before the one we just finished code
Veronica
[ __ ] you that's it that was no no no
he's not that oh that just it's a
knock-back thing so I should just keep
running around why so I'm not trying to
kill them right now I'm just trying to
survive until the church bell rings once
you play it enough you kind of like it's
one of those things like the church a
little ring okay I can't remember if
this there was people saying that I
think you can shoot the church bell if
you have if you have good enough aim
like but it's pretty far away I also
don't know if that's a myth or not
well he's stuck no he's not not no I'm
not so yeah to clarify there's a one-hit
kill if he gets me oh yeah so that was
kind of a yeah I could go up the barn
ladder so this is something resin evil
resident evil kind of lost in general
the like survival scenarios I guess this
isn't even really survival cred the
early games but like the where you can
didn't file yeah didn't biohazard have
something like that yeah so 7 brought a
lot of that back yeah that game is
fantastic alright that was the that was
one part I was semi worried about right
now now you're good
uh yeah I think so well this game
doesn't really ever let up and like I
said it'll get harder as I go but that
was the first real thing oh [ __ ] I'm
sorry I skipped down on a really cheesy
line forgot what he said actually okay
get this back out quick okay I'm just
gonna bear with me while I collect some
stuff for ammo item wise so yellow herbs
increase your overall health actually
I'm gonna before I forget for those of
you just joining us this is grave
hoppers where we put hermit death into
every game you die in a game you move on
to the next this is where we're at we're
at resident evil this is not up to date
in the sense that I think we're probably
what maybe five ten minutes and already
the Resident Evil yeah last game was
Last of Us where I tied very quickly in
25 seconds we're just gonna try to
forget about that
yeah it was good um I mean I'll go for
the blue targets because they'll
eventually get they might get me the
what weapon doesn't unlock the weapon it
unlocks wings zero it's not come to mind
right now the handgun that it unlocks
sorry the black something I think I got
everything from here I could shoot that
chicken okay
wing zero says are you surviving or
going to go for collectable that's what
I was just saying I missed that so yeah
so there's these blue medallion thank
you shoot and when you get enough of
them you unlock this one gun from the
merchant then you can buy so it's worth
it yeah it doesn't take up too much
space just these things you shoot like I
there's one around here actually we get
to the barn quick sorry good question
how come rest of the wild is up next
well I had a long thought last weekend
about how horribly I played in Last of
Us and I don't want to do the same for
alien isolation so I have never played
Island alien isolation or at least not
enough to I can build my idealist yeah
and I am so I swapped those so I could
get more time with alien isolation I
just finally got to the part where the
alien appears it's like for me I I was
playing kind of casually but like took
like an hour and a half to get to the
actual alien a cat and mouse stuff so I
wanted to get better at that because I
hear it's kind of tricky right with like
holding your breath and lockers and like
avoiding it I don't know it sounds like
you would want to have a pretty strong
understanding of how to avoid getting
killed by the alien this that's one life
are you gonna play zelda on master mode
you said yeah cool get the shotgun
shells alright
here we go sorry yeah
no fall damage each UPS that no fall
damage I wouldn't have even let me jump
if I couldn't yeah yeah in that case all
right so I'm just making sure I got
everything possible I think I did
there's no blue jewel here yet
I think the first ones up here coming up
but uh oh no it's right here I think
nope okay cool just don't wanna miss out
on em or anything yeah that being said
we're going through games kind of
quickly I mean now that too I think well
I think we'll be on resonable for a
while
which is nice to make up for a lot of
time I guess none taken wing zero but uh
so these things right here is what they
were he was mentioning here she was
mentioning if you have any suggestions
for games put it in the comments or in
the chat I missed handgun rounds
apparently uh because I think tell you
may I go back there about the changes
doesn't it well we'll be updating the
list is where I'm getting at as far as
new games cuz I think we're gonna need
missing point so here's a little thing
if you if I were to shoot that down
here's a nice piece of jewelry now and
it would drop to the dirty water it'd be
worth less oh [ __ ] god damn it I've
ruined it I'm sorry so you shoot this
and it falls down but I accidentally
press it to me so it's a dirty pearl
that goes now come on
[Music]
yeah you're dead
man there are some parts later in this
game that just they're stressful as hell
even if like I'm doing really well
get there get there get there girl
damn it wall jerk splinter cell's one
stealth games yeah that's what we're
kind of going for with the last of us a
little bit he's not an assassin but we
also we're looking at other stealth
games cuz that'd be doesn't be tense
I only nice elation even Zelda has some
stuff like that it won't be it's not
like game over if you get caught but
it's uh some stolen mega Chris wants to
know if you're playing on normal or this
is not normal we haven't I haven't
unlocked Pro Mode in this yet so this is
unnormal but obviously the dynamic
difficulty is still here the only time I
got far on the ps4 version it's not on
this system oh [ __ ] should have uh I
guess I could have cloud saved it but
chaos theory I was gonna ask which
Splinter Cell
Chamorro asks does Ashley dying count I
don't know that means um I don't that's
a good question I so you escort Ashley
Graham later I don't know we've got
enough time to figure that out actually
and maybe if you guys want to sound off
right now so yeah and she not die what
do you mean
does actually die if you if you die yes
if she dies when you're escorting her
which is a large portion of the game
then you that's a foul state you don't
die at Leon doesn't die but you may he
can but Ashley dying is a foul state so
that's the so that's the thing like do
we you want is it only if I die it's
only if you die okay because it's all
because you would still go back yeah
yeah I can see that this game has
infamous escort missions notorious I
mean technically I don't think that
counts cuz you're not me a dying i but
like I could I could see a spy case
thing like in blood-borne where you're
talking about we play blood-borne at
some point then the werewolf the
beginning will probably die there so we
can just get the game moving
Jesus
oh he's in here with me isn't he
oh no he's up top
damn it okay I might as well increase my
overall health
yellow raises it in refills Foley's jerk
yes he's not technically a deaf but it's
like it's tense cuz you're worrying
about both you at that point I feel like
if I was I would need it to progress but
no I already know okay
actually wait one more thing I think
that's everything for now got that doors
locked so I got it I think there's one
more jewel I didn't get mice already
shot it nope there was one really far
down there hey what oh yeah I could call
shakey
I'll get loose that's tough
okay sweet on to the mines ich area kind
of that's doing oh whoops I need Ashley
for that I'm going the other way and
there's one up there in the barn
it's rather to punch in this area
how would I miss that already dang I
don't want slows down too much bone and
get that stuff I'm just trying to
survive wait
thirsty there
Oh through this window maybe yeah
yeah Mary's coming in tomorrow to play
zero huh forgot how to get in there
shoot something blocking that no maybe
oh I gotta jump down from the top uh huh
that's not I don't think sweet how about
one of the Uncharted we're trying to
avoid very story heavy games I want to
say yeah oh god no no oh god this could
be bad see that's an instant death if I
didn't do that right and it's either
Square and X or that could have been the
two triggers I'm glad I did not remember
that until now but oh my god oh [ __ ] my
heart's racing my heart's racing as soon
as I saw them I can say anything cuz
your reaction so that part's theirs I
forgot about those parts in this game
they're [ __ ] how long has it been
since you played this year no less than
that yeah I play this game like yearly
so maybe you're right yeah you're like
in the fall dang you are I'm sweating
well cuz so that could have been oh so
it was like the Proms could been
different huh it's there it's one of two
it's X and square or r2 and l2
it is jamoke Oh with this dynamite I'm
not even gonna it usually get to shoot
that I'll shoot the dynamite
oh yeah let's let him die clear your
throat alright um I remember there's a
mine there I'm just gonna shoot this
many of you to bother dodging in case I
run into it you jerk
fog oh [ __ ] yep that's gonna hurt me oh
thank god that triggered the other one
these guys are such dicks don't you like
that oh oh my god behind you is
everything he's letting you know they're
coming out of the floor no it's the the
it's they're them if it like boiling
evaporating no this is unnormal lapis
lazuli
[Music]
come on you jerk shoot the damn got it
here we go
green herb nice no now up oh damn it I
it's embarrassing okay there are others
here too somewhere over that way
this camera doesn't make it easy oh this
is when you meet uh actually no el jefe
no the chief he's one of the dudes you
fight there's a there he's a pretty
decent boss fight not now but I meet him
here and you get infected
don't forget the bird's nest oh good
call
Thanks
it's a weird looking egg it was a jewel
you put into something later to make it
more valuable
that's good question Mario how long does
it finish take to finish this game um if
it's your first time playing could be
anywhere from like 16 to 20 I think I do
it and a lot of people once they play it
a lot probably doing around ten for the
purpose of this because I'm not saving
and because I'm kind of I could see it
being like twelve if I get through it
but it's also like it doesn't feel that
long as this game is like a master class
in pacing
yeah I'm kind of also trying to not
speed through but like oops no bear
traps Lewis
how much how much longer do I have Oh 40
minutes half an hour I'm not worried
no you oh sorry
sweet moving on saving doesn't matter
wasting time at this point no just go
oh I'll proceed alright so Salazar
Sadler Sadler infected me with Las
Plagas oh my god
forgot about that that happened really
quickly I know I forgot about it how did
you end up here so quickly uh it skipped
through a few cutscenes I get you get
knocked out by someone at the beginning
of chapter and then I'm infected god
damn dude there's a few more of those
there's one where I'm uh there's another
Boulder that rolls after me
so me and Louise Louise escaped if you
get the prompt wrong does it oh you're
dead that's one yeah yeah there's the
merchant
my open doors oh geez I got coming up
soon No so this is where it gets
interesting what do I spend my money on
what do I buy I normally like to avoid
getting the TMP I know that's a
difference of philosophy from a lot of
people and then just sell the TMP mo but
a lot of people like having it to fill
in so it's not just rifle and handgun in
shotgun I think for this run I'm going
to get the TMP anything I can right now
I'm keeping the chicken eggs for health
[Music]
I don't need a bigger inventory yet or
the treasure map rifle or TMP I wonder
I'll go rifle for this part - not my
handgun maybe or my shotgun
[Music]
yeah I don't need to I guess I'll save
money for sure so this part could be
this part could be bit troubling should
I clean up a cinnamon Torre right now
yeah at least do that alright let me
just make sure I got this sensitivity
down
okay here we go yes seems like people
are on board with it rifle wow he did
yep
so do with dynamite to that I want to
kill right now
where's yet Oh posse damn it
where stairs right here I'm just gonna
wait it out here all you dick
reload please
good thing they suck at throwing
kicking balls yeah yeah
sure I would a knife to the player
dynamite dynamite yeah
I do it right I can get him to blow
everyone else up people she drops behind
me oh that was the pickaxe II just threw
yeah you just shoot the dynamite in fact
ah damn it I'm gonna heal just to be
safe yeah believe would and mm-hmm red
or green gonna waste a red right now I
might as well
stop that stop throwing that
oh my god I'm empty there's something
funny about ya guys oh no I'm mutate ya
today ah damn it there's something funny
about our guy just shootin like five
people's kneecaps continues oh my god I
gotta reload sorry that was stupid I'm
not paying attention
oh he got the reload off
damnit
I'm gonna help its base before you shot
him
beep several people have mentioned Ninja
Gaiden black you realize we would
survive for maybe 20 minutes if we
worked good that's a good suggestion
though I'll admit oh damn it it was a
red barrels yeah your favorite rifle oh
yeah I can't do the old-school reloading
before I forget I'm gonna reload
area
ooh the frame rate on this reload
animation okay like doing I never know
what they're doing
oh nice throw dick
how is he like I don't know they have
lighters on them fingernails yeah I got
a first dates right say that's good
don't you throw that up here you jerk
okay
yeah
I just dude next means not gotta keep
that in mind
come here pretties
alright give me a lie I don't want money
right now
a couple more
where to go damn am i late again
one more up above me I think
I don't think there's anybody in here
but just in case
yeah that this rifles Barry Opie
oh [ __ ]
nope
stay down
a couple things in here I could get MLS
[Music]
here a guy yeah he's upstairs I think
who DNC would be good to character
action means general will be fun
turn around me yes on this
[Music]
god those items don't take up space
no merchants challenged oh I don't solve
this show's already hard enough
[Music]
I hate ladders [ __ ] this
sorry oh that's kind of smart I'm just
realizing you do that too
yeah if they're climbing up that you can
kick right whoops I gotta go to the
other side for the other piece that key
bellevue this first comeback where you
come from
so is this another survival moment or is
there's a fine idea about dudes here I
have two rounds why did that let me
reload if I there's gonna be quick
that guy looks nice yeah
[ __ ] they have not started Mutai yeah
but just thankful which is great
a lot times tentacles come out of their
head they're at the Las Vegas
nice
nice sidestep the other guy done to all
that sidestep working out wow you got a
lot of guys to kill
this was dumb I think going up here uh I
got time to reload and I could jump down
I just want to reload
ha ye that's right
good night
that barrel to that yeah yeah can you
follow up No thank God
oh they went the other way
I don't think anybody's buying this
jamoke I walked into that one
I should heal I guess he's first day
it's great I guess I want to risk is
that all you have now right now yeah
[Laughter]
I'm not out of ambos [ __ ]
sure barrel
every cow musicsoft we know that we're
safe use more health than I would have
preferred but I guess that's without the
chance of responding and I guess I'm a
little being a little less risky taking
fewer risks I think I got the key the
barrel up there I should open did I get
handgun ammo thank you Oh what was that
oh she's jumping over okay cool they
didn't drop as much stuff as I would
have liked I am more risk-averse thank
you Eric okay so you I'm happy with how
this is going where is it that barrel
oh and I gotta go in this check nice use
that to free up space for those of you
just joining us this is grave hoppers
the show we put Herman death in every
game we die in a game we move on to the
next here's our list
we're on resident evil we're looking
we're looking pretty good I think we're
gonna we're gonna do a whole episode of
Resident Evil definitely if that's the
case where he are showing the polar
opposites of the show last weekend
that's right last week was we jokingly
called it the red wedding that was
against three four five yeah that was a
third episode games three four five I
died to fall damage and halo combat
Evolved Mike got invaded and cornered on
a bridge and then I died horribly I died
horribly in lots of us with a minute and
25 seconds it was real embarrassing I
didn't sleep that night people are
comparing Leon and Chris I wish I could
pay more attention to conversation
because I have some input I prefer Leon
but they both have their merits
dominated by gravity I've been dominated
by gravity twice
yeah thanks Sarah a far cry and halo
how'd you do last of us was just [ __ ]
feet down just a beat down I like ran up
to they honestly it was an honest
mistake like I I guess I should have
because you asked me you're like what's
different on grandma's like it's just
harder I didn't tell you there's no
prompts or like Hut at all that's one
thing I should have told you I should
have played it in a chapter no not the
other chefs are so there's a part come
up with Lewis people might remember when
I'm defending this cabin where it's just
swarms of people that could be
problematic that's all about like when I
use my health and stuff I mean I'm sure
people will say no it's not that hard
but it can be I guess it'll take some
some thinking some alright some stuff in
here I don't want to mess up well you
might drop the cheese and some mud you
might spill the milk on the fire what
the hell are you talking about
oh you dropped a jewel oh into the to
the high Jewish muddy water no where's
your bathroom
yeah that's a good point Chris does
punch boulders when Leon
nice throw
oh [ __ ] sorry go
damnit
someone else anybody
I think if someone through here
take it there we go
anybody behind me over here no I think
I'm good
oh it's sensitive I'm actually not
familiar with resident evil at all I've
only played a little bit of biohazard
and most recent not the person to be
picking a favorite of the series is this
my favorite Resident Evil no remake is
but two is a close second and then this
actually seven is up there I really
really like seven it's not my favorite
but um I'm really excited for a remake i
I have no problem with what they're
doing with the third person action more
orientation I like it
yeah remake of my favorite remakes one
of my favorite games ever of any genre
god damn it I forgot about this part
this sucks yeah climb over step in the
bear traps Oh dread help oh I have to
use the coal bag oh my god dude you had
no health you had no health you had no
Helen let's not talking about blow past
it I really owe like a phoenix from the
ashes God there wasn't any red I know I
thought I was dead dude if I did not use
that yellow Irv earlier to increase my
max health that would have killed me
[Music]
lianna's kennedy liked it oh my god so
the rifle made that problematic because
I had to stop and aim like
and then I remember there were bear
traps here so I slowed down a little bit
I looked away did you shoot the grenade
and mineral I I I should have hung back
here but they threw it and I just two of
them dead yeah they both hit me like
initially by themselves oh okay I think
I'm good on grenades I don't man that
handgun the lack of him handgun ammo is
really annoying me is there a bear shop
right here no good the music the drums
yeah it's I'm gonna I don't need to get
these I just don't want to actually step
on them later if I'm you got to get this
perfect angle
just in case I jump over that I thought
you died it looked like you had died do
it as soon as I saw him get ready to do
the kickflip back up I was like holy
[ __ ] I got lucky it was that it was the
yellow herb from earlier otherwise I
would have depleted my help yeah I have
flirted with death quite a few times
today oh dude that cat had nine lives he
just spent all night of them oh man oh
the oven thing is there anything yes
fire these roots in the fire oh you
scared me
sorry oh there we go
handgun times I got 12 minutes left
let's see if this will be this will be
monumental this will be historical for
the show if I can survive a whole
episode with one game there a bear trap
here how'd they not step on these that's
such [ __ ] why don't they abide by
the same rules I shouldn't be
complaining about what's fair not fair
right now after I just got married to
death and then got a divorce um okay
nothing in here I don't think go through
here get this thing I'm not gonna sell
it yeah I'm gonna put the stuff in there
pretty yeah
[Music]
wing zero says your luck is running out
no I'm good oh yeah actually you know
what I just I don't know it just
occurred to me why the hell am I even
saving yellow herbs right now
so I'm saving like I normally would save
them I guess I should yeah I'll save
till I get a read so I get the full heal
is that smart yeah the rules of this
game change when you're not using it
when you're just not taking any risks I
guess the whole show is a risk the
merchant being Sadler I've read that
like theory on reddit a few times I
never really got into how they justify
it like ever why he would be helping you
are you doing I'm just making sure I'm
not yeah there's some times you turn
around there's a jewel hanging above you
everything I got go back
alright there's so many farmers down
here I know yeah eventually you fight
creepy dudes like this game gets you
fight these dudes who like mumble
they're like monks like ok there's a
long drop he does that in this game
give me your scale what the hell there
we go oh do I have enough space I gotta
rearrange your stuff I culture delicious
bass did I do that right it's like a
little mini this even worse worth a fish
can I get this in here I totally can but
I'm need ammo oh [ __ ] nope I should be
good oh you can
ah [ __ ] yes ok there's another one down
here too I should just eat him now I
guess I'll eat that one now actually let
me make sure he actually drops when I
think it can not drop them flash grenade
nice
do I want more fish sure okay sweet got
the full health from the fish thank you
I don't have room for another one god
that looks so dumb and creepy and gross
reload anything no pretty good on ammo
to empty your pockets
empty your pockets early right from a
rifle a job it took bass what were you
doing what were you doing with this sir
what was your endgame I got a little lag
on the stream doing I don't know
here we go I got it this time Rob see
it's worth instead of a thousand four
think it's 2000 I don't remember
2500 is this a snake people nope there's
sometimes snakes in there that just jump
out of you and I hate their specific
yeah I think maybe it is ran on that oh
sorry I can't even bother with the
shooting it actually this is where you
can learn back is just that oh no
actually this is the that's the part
with chief
Mike we're gonna call it in seven
minutes just like actually [ __ ] this is
coming up to a part where I could yeah
or or a good part to end it like it also
just occurred to me I do need to save
because if I survive an episode I need
to have a starting point for next time
but this game also lets you actually was
there a typewriter back no there was not
there's one up here I think okay well
let's end it at a typewriter then nope
sorry that was wrong kill you that no I
was right wow that and now up yeah
that's not it
oh that's upside down oh sorry yeah it
was upside down no not at all
there we go I'll be honest I wasn't
thinking too much oh there's a
typewriter alright sweet uh Wow let me
uh so I got a the Lewis fight coming up
and like that's not a typewriter I got
the boss fight coming up Big Chief and
they check behind these paintings same
painting later on you can check behind
them is that now I could've sworn those
now maybe not in here yeah I wants to
ride the lake monster
I own the lake monster damn this should
be a cutscene and save cool so I'll save
this and then we'll call it here what
was my hit ratio 82% I'm bad yeah okay
let's call here let's good time or do we
want to stick to it yeah yeah yeah I
don't know that's good time we played
for an hour mmm all right that's gonna
do it um yeah as a Konami code
nice Mike you did it alright I'm good
you told ya he gon say or the chainsaw
sisters coming up who should I fight
I'll figure that out that's a choice I
could have to make for a boss fight man
Wow thank God for that yellow herb yeah
you almost died historic occasion what
episode five four and we we survived the
whole thing that's right
man we're looking good so I would I
would clock that at just under an hour
yeah if you join later the show we tried
to survive for an hour in each game if
we die move on to the next game there
were three deaths last week for three
different games you can see here but
today we survived all over zero for the
whole hour so yeah next week we'll
continue with reading before right from
this save mm-hmm thank you for the
congratulations I've got some tough
times coming up got the I got the del
Lago this Lake Monsters and the Lago so
it's it's weird it's not like you're in
a boat and you're throwing harpoons and
it's not QuickTime events but it's like
button mashing it's what you can so you
can slip in a way yes I should
definitely do a league on say I agree
there's a part where branches and you
can do two different bosses but yeah
I've got one more of those Boulder
things coming up that scared me I forgot
about that until yeah today there are
some scary moments in this where's the
latter half of this episode got lucky
those Dynamite's did just enough damage
to not kill me it didn't even look like
I had health left I'm still shaking a
little bit yeah I am as well you done
good Mike that's gonna do it for this
episode number four and yeah stay tuned
every Thursday 2 p.m. Pacific and we'll
pick up on Resident Evil 4 next week
this was your first episode and you want
to see how we got to resin evil and live
the embarrassment no there's some good
the first episode was like all Far Cry
pretty much yeah I'd you know and you
essentially surround the whole episode
and then we started doomed technically
yeah definitely and go back and watch
those they're archived
and if you cherish your time and you
don't want to stick to an hour-long
episodes the beginning of each episode
we've been doing kind of like previously
previously on so about two to a minute
long highlights so you can just watch
those at the beginning of each episode
if you just want to get caught up real
quick to where we are now and you can be
practicing Zelda in the meantime I don't
need practice elbow anymore I've played
enough so that 450 hours something I'm
it's like I'm like I'm close to 700
hours and say so I'm fine I haven't but
I haven't played in a while people
language not the planes I was not worth
it I'm not I shouldn't know it's young
it's fine but yeah alien isolation after
that we can take another look it's just
gonna be zelda after Resident Evil at
some point if you if you die then its
Metal Gear Solid 5 reach so we changed
alien isolation and Zelda because I
haven't played enough isolation to be
comfortable with it so I got a bunch of
good suggestions and like a list is
mainly too broad structure we I think at
this point I mean it's not official yet
but we're kind of already planning a few
games to go past that this is just like
the initial pilot season I guess you
might call it we've got--we've people
were recommending a bunch of good games
mm-hmm well yeah well I mean well yeah
so we'll go cuz we went very fast last
episode we're very quickly we went three
yeah we will update those uh I'm gonna
cut the highlight reel today or whatever
sure this week so you can catch up I'm
gonna have to relive that anxiety yeah
cool cool winning as always thank you so
much guys and that's it we'll see you
all in five stream tomorrow morning same
time as always that's right tomorrow's
the last episode of games about daily
our new show Kelly Michael and then
we're gonna scream a game as always me
and Mary recording tomorrow are you
doing anything no man sky no man sky
stuff but yeah and then starting next
weekend count on live streaming every
day at 11 a.m. Pacific see you later
that's it have a great rest of the week
[Music]
you